hey guys righteous Ryan here virtuous
Veronica we're gonna watch some TV spots
for a little movie a little independent
film called Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
no Veronica have you seen anything about
it the only thing I've seen about
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is the
movie that came out in the 90s the 90s
which one there was three what
there was three yeah there's three than
the first one what happened in it that
was a little girl and I watched it but I
watched all time there was these teenage
and they had the rat master uncle the
guy splitter winner yeah it was a really
cool it was the bad guy there was those
dudes there was those dudes and then
there was these kids and then the kids
put something in one of the dudes start
an Asian guy
no yeah wait was he a pizza delivery boy
yes that's part two I didn't know that
yeah
Ernie Reyes jr. those movies are [ __ ]
awesome I love all three of them I can't
believe I haven't maybe I have seen them
I just don't remember
dude we should have a marathon one day
suddenly have you seen any of the
trailers for this new one I saw one of
your trailer reactions I think okay well
yeah I mean I loved those first three
and the cartoon was great I mean I have
a little bit of worry that about this
film and it looks fun and entertaining
but now that I'm remembering how much I
actually loved so much of the franchise
already now I'm a little bit worried
like what if this sucks
so I'm a little worried too of what
they're what they're doing with it I
mean it's gonna be pretty intense it's
like a another Transformers movie yeah
that's pretty much it
all right this is TV spot number five
it's gonna be three TV spots we were
created as weapons
and we knew the world would never accept
this when they get what need us
see that
you're talking tarnish
like it looks cool I mean even though
Michael Bay only produced it it still
looks like Michael Bay's Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles it is a concern I've been
having with all these trailers they're
so action-packed which is awesome sure
but at the same time it's like I love
the Turtles because of who they are as
people who they are is carry on yeah and
I'm like I want to see their personality
shine more on these trailers and stuff I
want to see actually like what makes
them each distinct from one another
other than the fact that there are four
turtles it's just yeah like I hope
there's more to it but yeah I mean like
the fun characterization is what's
really cool about the Turtles and
everything else thinking when I was
watching it now that I'm remembering the
90s one the 90s one was like there were
people in costumes really good makeup
effects and stuff and in this one it's
all CGI which kind of is a letdown to me
cuz I like I mean Planeta say like the
reboot of Planet of the Apes rise and
Donner like really good films and they
change the Apes to be from prosthetic to
CGI and outworked
so might work in this one but I kind of
liked the idea that they were like
prosthetics before I think the words
prosthetics I don't know anyway were you
gonna say I'm sorry you had an opinion
and I [ __ ] it up like to just too far
I can't retrieve that I'm sorry anyway
there's two more we gotta watch TV slot
number six people training is not
complete you will be the warriors that
legends
still figuring out the buns Mikey's the
stupid one it looks cool it's just more
it's just a dude movie I mean it looked
like they had a little bit more
character this time around they were
actually going like weird brains
attitude I really relate a lot with
Raphael I think he's the most relatable
for a lot of people because of his
badass attitude you know kind of like
rough side of the streets kind of dude
you know because I'm like that dark
mysterious you know yeah like I think
I'm someone who's very mysterious like
I'm not open about anything really I'm
the last person to talk about like my
emotions my sexuality my sex thoughts
many times I masturbate I think it's
very healthy actually very healthy like
I think answers some law things like the
Turtles if there was a female turtle
probably masturbator
just saying over Megan Fox and yeah I'm
kidding Megan Fox oh she's a hottie but
like she was born April O'Neil and the
Ninja Turtles moot it was showing movies
sorry didn't she know she had a kid and
stuff no her face is a lot different she
gained weight to 45 didn't she get like
no she was like really skinny and then
she gained like it wasn't about her
weight it was about her face her facial
structure I don't know I don't care she
looks hot so good job but yeah Megan Fox
is April O'Neil like there's been a lot
of backlash about that because April
O'Neil is a very important character the
fact that they're like barely showing
her and the trailers is kind of giving I
mean like they're probably doing it cuz
of the backlash but then also they're
probably also doing it because their
footage is not that great so they're not
showing it right I'm sorry I have
concerns now it's weird I didn't have
all these concerns before
different video guys it's different from
the other two turbo videos cuz for Lana
cos here cuz he's letting you guys down
right now you bring out my darkness
let's watch the next now we had a lot
more fun yeah that one has like the
turtles they show that they do have like
personality yeah okay a lot of my
concerns are goin does like badass like
you know I love watching martial arts
action sequences
thank you guys last on those TV spots
were out if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe here please if you
want to then Veronica has her own show
you mean if you want to they're gonna
subscribe whether or not they subscribe
I don't care if you like it or if you
don't like it you better [ __ ]
subscribe are you holding a gun it was
pointing you're pointing like this I was
it was a very serious point I'm pretty
sure you thought you were holding a gun
for a second well is this some kind of
started spreading out as I was going so
kind of like when people points this
when people do this it's a gun you but
you Veronica has a channel too it's like
my area of expertise on that channel so
Who am I kidding I'm not an expert yep I
play these hard I sing song great do
covers check it out
Jarnell Crisler wanted a shout out I'm
willing to earn a shout out mr. Ryan
so what's up well mr. jarred now you've
just earned a shout-out by asking for
one that's how easy it is turn to shout
out his channel dude buddy you worked
hard you took your time to use your
fingers and hit that keyboard and then
ask me a question so yes you have earned
a shout-out congratulations
show me your tits Veronica show me your
tits don't let him down show me your
tits I want to see your tits Rock Laura
Silva area hi names Laura that's your
mom's name yes it is I know a lot of
Laura's man they're all hot wanna
banging each and every one of them
including your mom give me a shout-out
and if you're watching missus 6 dos
what's up baby
and if you're watching mr. 6 dos don't
mean any of that but if you're not
watching I mean every word of that Laura
give me a shout-out and then be nicer to
your girl what girl was that Alyssa
because she makes a show worth watching
only kidding love you both you do an
awesome job and make it look like a lot
of fun keep up the good work
thanks Laura Thanks you're going on that
list of Laura's I want to do things with
congratulations Laura you got to have a
thumbnail picture you don't have a
thumbnail picture of yourself what am I
gonna think of tonight that's not Laura
what if that's bill it says Laura so
who's bill Laura
you're a good girl stay that way make
sure to keep those legs closed until
marriage okay you don't want to
disappoint the Lord Jesus don't have sex
until marriage if you have sex before
that you're gonna feel the wrath of
Satan
you understand I'd like to give
comforting [ __ ] Grum Ramon Stafford
Dragon Ball Z movie is finally coming to
America it looks awesome and you guys
are so funny shout out please
well thank you for saying I am funny
because it makes me feel good she and he
said you guys so Marie and Dan were in
that video but I'm sure she
was a frame you I mean I don't have
comments about I can't no harder from
the videos that I'm in it takes for no
people ask for you on videos or not in
will get your [ __ ] together you know how
hard it is to organize these shoutouts
organize your [ __ ] I'm not caught up on
Commons so then I got to go to shoutouts
to where I haven't even replied back to
that comment yet you know how hard it is
to keep up with all this today damn a
remote see you wanted a [ __ ] shout
out now look what's happening all
because you wanted a shout out Ramon